yo what's Poppin it's your boy Simba
y'all check me out right here on the
bullet Kev podcast
shows
come on on the very first day of my new
career yes as a bipper yes I decided to
cancel the podcast I'm gonna move to San
Francisco yes and I'm going to pays very
well yeah I'm just gonna play the odds
game I'm a bit everybody look for every
rental and hopefully I hit like a you
know a nice you know hopefully Draymond
slipping one day uh oh whoa Draymond
ain't gonna be slipping obviously
draymond's never going to slip never
yeah he's never going to slip he's
always ready for action uh Draymond was
at your uh concert at the Roxy that's my
brother super nice guy yes great guy I
saw him out back and uh chopped it up
with him he did a video saying hi to my
son yeah
um
so talk to me about your uh conference
have you talked to him since he knocked
out Jordan pool
ain't done with a little bit of
straightening yeah you know
I feel like families fight right Fringe
fight right things happen right you know
um and you know they just you know they
had to get some just get a little bit of
frustration though that's all it was it
wasn't nothing too crazy so how bad does
he want to be a Laker
I don't know you would have to talk
he's your friend he's not my friend we
don't talk about those things I gotta
ask I don't ask because at your concert
he was sitting next to LeBron James and
his wife he loves it in L.A Jordan pool
wasn't at your concert you know kamingo
was in there you know Draymond and
LeBron were there yeah you know well if
that if that does happen right let's say
that does happen which I don't think it
will happen when that does happen let's
see I don't think it will I think he'll
be a lawyer you don't think that you're
just saying that because we're being
recorded I think he'll be a lawyer
you're full of [ __ ] let's say let's say
that does happen Okay okay how do you
see that working
I think if Russell Westbrook is gone
okay
and they give him like comparable salary
to what he's making now which I think is
like 27 million dollars yeah they could
probably afford to get another player
at a front Court of
A.D and Draymond yeah
I'm not mad at it but the problem with
the Lakers is they still don't have
nobody who can shoot they don't have no
shooters
so it's like could we get Draymond and
Jordan pool I think you could push if
you push some shoes I said we like I'm a
[ __ ] Laker fan I'm a LeBron you are a
Laker I'm not I'm a Sons fan I don't
like the Suns you just root for them
because you're from there no you're a
Laker fan listen bootleg Kev podcast no
no no I'm gonna tell y'all what he does
I'm a LeBron let me tell y'all what he
does when he's not in Phoenix he wears
Lakers gear he goes to Lakers games
that's not true he celebrates Lakers
wins he just don't let y'all see this
[ __ ] because he got this Phoenix monkey
on his back he's a liar I'm telling you
the truth I've seen him in this Suite
with a LeBron James Laker jersey on you
haven't yes I have I've never worn a
LeBron Lakers jersey in my life I'm
probably making it up but I've seen you
in the suite rooting for the Lakers I
have um every LeBron Jersey in my closet
except the Lakers no I have one so you
see that y'all he has the [ __ ] Jersey
but he wears the Jersey to the games
I've seen it I have it for collection
purposes yeah right I'm in I'm I'm
LeBron is like my my favorite player
ever okay so if you go into my office I
have like a LeBron toy so what do you
think your sons are going to do this
year because they lost you some money
last year
and a little bit of embarrassment
um I think it's gonna be rough it's
gonna be rough because DeAndre Aiden
don't want to be there Jay Crowders
trying to get the [ __ ] up out of there I
sure got KD we tried I don't think you
tried hard enough why you're probably
right we should have just said whatever
what do you want yeah give him what he
wants yeah he's the goat
hopefully by January 15th he's unhappy
there and ayton is tradable and then we
we we [ __ ] make the swap I'm a golden
state Laker so this the suns are not so
what that tells me is you are a Laker
fan growing up because of Kobe but then
the Warriors got good and you're like
it's convenient because I'm from the bay
let's go Warriors you were very close
you were very very close I know a lot of
people first the first half yes but it
was the We Believe Warriors team for me
with Baron Davis Matt Barnes Stephen
Jackson Michael Petrus yeah it was that
Jason Richardson it was that team was
was bidrons on that team the center the
white guy from I think he was yeah I
think he was on that team but that's
when I became a real Warriors fan so you
were a Warriors fan for like that run
and then they sucked again not but even
when they sucked Iraq so yeah early
staff years early stiff then clay came
Draymond came yeah I remember me and Bam
went to the uh the series when they
first went to the playoffs and played
the Spurs in the second round
I think it was around 2014 2015
somewhere around there but that's we
kind of started to see like okay the
Warriors
yeah when they first made it to the
second round that's when we kind of knew
like the words but Mark Jackson was a
coach yes sir and they got my boy out of
there and they brought him back since
yeah it's crazy he hasn't got another
job yeah I think he offended the wrong
people yes for the NBA's mildly racist
at least we know that's why he didn't
get hired by the Suns because the owner
was right I'm kidding the our coach is
black and so is our GM hey that doesn't
mean the owner can't be racist oh he's a
piece of [ __ ] and he's out of there I
hope Jeff Bezos buys the team they're
saying of Jeff Bezos by the team it's
going downhill what does that mean we
got the red we'll always be in the
luxury tax no you guys he'll be the
richest owner in the league by far just
living the luxury tax like y'all do you
guys will be flying spaceships to the
games I like it you know you'll you'll
just be two in the future to win I don't
see it well listen man I got to give you
props the new album is out thank you
it's I got a bone to pick with you too
tape why because
you call Freddie Gibbs album of the year
over months I think his album's better
than better than okay what's your
opinion I think I think you got I think
I got you around five
okay I put the list together the other
day okay you're about five so who's the
four before me I got Freddy Kendrick
Pusha T and jid and then Simba
that's disrespectful
you know what's disrespectful is the
songs you keep losing leaving off these
[ __ ] projects no my fault I can't get
[ __ ] cleared no you got this [ __ ] it
was a black Jesus
oh yeah that's the only song yeah but
that [ __ ] should be honest it's crazy
it'll come soon let me tell you
something but I respect your opinion you
know you know your mind no you're up
there I put the list together like
literally if it makes what makes those
albums better
I just think that they're I just think
they're better well I don't know what
you want me to lie to you I was like
better because they're more like you're
friends with them no you're I'm closer
friends with you than everybody but
Freddy like I love you bro like I'm
waving your flag all the time I know I
wave your flag all the time I want to
put you I they're down I'm not jid's
been on my show Once he's a nice guy
what makes j.i.d's album better than
mine
I just think front to back it's it's
just I just think it's stronger okay
yeah but you don't have a reason you
just think I think jid's album
conceptually super crazy he's got a song
called Mom and them on there I just
think it's like to Me jid's album
and I think that the top three or four
albums of the year are all pretty close
yeah like some days I might feel like
it's push or some days I might feel like
it's Kendra I think the top three is
like Freddy Kendrick uh push in any
order okay but then I think it's like
jid it's you it's Denzel Curry uh Joey
Badass album
shout out Joey his album is dope uh
Conway's album Benny shout out to jid
too I [ __ ] with jids out I just wanted
also also also your shit's a mixtape
yeah you have DJ Drama host it yeah but
what's a mixtape compared to album no I
agree I agree I'm just I'm just so I
would say that uh you are I just feel
like some [ __ ] got left off this project
no only thing that really got left was
it was a beat we couldn't get cleared
I would say this
I think that your album is great okay
and I think that you have some of the
more like dope relatable [ __ ] and I
think that
there are I think that some of the like
records I don't prefer on the album were
probably like the key Glock record
um hello there Rick
yeah I don't what I don't know just not
crazy about it that's the record does
the Jeffrey dude on that record yeah
yeah yeah
but I didn't like that record um when
you played it for me before key Glock
was on it I like it I think it's a great
performance record it brings a lot of
energy the album is dope though no no
it's a great album I know I'm not saying
it's not I'm saying I'm trying to make
you like the song
it's not that I hate it it's just that I
just like
I don't know I feel like
um
can't wait for nothing is one of my
favorite songs of the year for sure I
told you like just on some yo let's talk
about this okay
can I open the cabinet a bit open it up
let's go
are you sure I'm ready Dr Dre cut a
verse you heard the verse yes didn't
make the album no
but that doesn't mean it's not coming
God tricks up the sleeve well you did
two parts to the song you got the first
part you got to push three it might be a
four
might be a five there's a few people
that like that beat
so that they've rap to it
um so I feel like we had a time today
where you could keep making your album
so Dr Dre was supposed to be on the on
the song
is he supposed to be on that song Or
maybe when this comes well I heard him
on that song but was it that version
I heard him on a version I feel like hmm
so what's it like uh by the way did you
help him write the record no
he
he like the way Dre works is like a
collaborative thing he might take a
liner to here take certain things but he
kind of knows what he wants to say right
so it's just more so like you kind of
just like so you did you help him with
the verse no no no no okay no I didn't
know him at all with the verse I just
pulled up one day and uh actually
the verse every time I never end that
broke yes yes never end up broke
um he actually laid diverse it was him
and them joints and I came to the studio
one day and he played it
wow you know we're figuring it out
exclusively right here on the bootleg
cave show this is the first time I've
ever said this
because I got to get permission to open
the cabinet a little you know well you
know you you you're my brother so yeah
I'm all for it uh uh I mean I think that
like having Dre obviously cosine is
crazy because he doesn't cosign a lot of
people that's
um how did uh that uh relationship
originally start so Dre has a nephew
who's a producer as well his name is
Keon right and I met Keon at a studio
session
he was like I'm gonna take you to meet
my uncle we ended up jumping on the
phone right
um
he was like after the Super Bowl I want
to link up with you and put some music
together Super Bowl passed about two
days later he hit me told me to pull up
to the crib I told everybody in the
studio I was going to the bathroom and I
never came back
wow so I left the studio and I went to
Dre's house and I was over there for
about four days wow just working I heard
his speakers at his house are crazy he's
Immaculate everything is like incredible
and what's so crazy is as loud as the
speakers are when you close the door to
the studio you can't hear nothing
it's just so you're just looking like
isolated oh I got you I got you it's
just like the room's just so quiet like
it's like you close the door like
imagine if we close that door like a
perfectly treated room yeah you wouldn't
hear nothing you could still like you
could if that was his studio and you
could turn the music all the way up and
close the door in the podcast what the
[ __ ] yeah and then what's crazy is he
has that same setup built in about like
two or three different Studios shout out
to Dre man the goat the goat the
greatest so how many records did y'all
do together
we have a few wow we have a record
that's really really really good
I wish she'd drop it is it on him to
drop it that one yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah it is really really good I think
it'll come out soon I think he's working
on something yeah I mean uh I've heard
yeah I've heard uh that you've uh you
you there's some uh potential stuff in
the works for you with a lot of artists
yeah yeah there was a particular record
that I really liked of yours that I told
Caston I was like man I'm just gonna ask
him for the song and just make it a boot
like Kev singer which one West Side
Griselda but he said that that verse
might make some big [ __ ] yeah
I put the verse somewhere else because
we couldn't get the sample clear big
that be the thing man these damn sample
clearances like some of my best verses
is like always over a sample and it's so
tough to clear these samples sometimes
it's tough and like if if you're like
you're on Atlantic so like I feel like
the sample clearer sees Atlantic and
they're like they just shoot for the
moon on how much they want it Robin
Thick made it hard for everybody
he did Robin Thick made it hard for a
lot because they won that lawsuit
against him right
Robert made it hard for us and uh
what was the other uh lawsuit that it
was Robin Thicke Blurred Lines and um oh
uh there was another one the Bruno Mars
or no no it was uh
was it Bruno Mars it was another one I
can't remember which one when it was but
it was another one but the Robin Thick
one was that was the one yeah they ate
yeah big time good for that big time Big
Time but sometimes I feel like
you know like for instance I had a
record that
is on the project but it's a different
beat behind it right right and I feel
like if the original beat was on it it
was out of here which record soul ties
okay I feel like um it was it would have
been a big massive record if the
original beat was what it was it was a
sample and it was a sample from a big
album
and the writer who passed away not gonna
say his name passed away and I think
2016.
he told his wife to never clear music
after he passes he wants his music to
live on the way that he made it but I
felt like the way to keep the music
living on is to and the way to keep
money in your family's Pockets yeah but
I ain't feel bad I feel bad because the
record is a smash but at the same time I
heard like
everybody's trying to clear the record
like I talked to two chains and he like
had a same sample with the same song he
couldn't get it cleared yeah lizzo oh
you know what
the two chains [ __ ] I wish that would
have been on your album
's gonna sell this though yeah yeah I
wish that would have been on your album
why because it was supposed to be
and that [ __ ] was that [ __ ] so hard and
I felt like it was just an album cut on
the [ __ ] 2 Chainz album as to where
if it was like yeah I'm slipped on for
sure y'all would have shot a [ __ ]
video to it yeah stove got Cooks on it I
feel like I think that's a great rap
record that song's so [ __ ] hard yeah
it's a great rap but but that's the
problem with it was like at the end of
his album like that's the problem with
streaming today it's like everything is
so curated to hear one specific sound
you would have shot that music video
though I would have shot the video for
sure that song's hard but I understand
why he did it you know like change I
mean you guys got three songs now yeah
it's about three that's out yeah I mean
I'm sure you got more we got great
chemistry though because I think like
I think would change
I bring out kind of like his rap side
you know everybody knows him for like
the biggest rap rap chains is a Lyricist
for sure chains get busy and I always
just love to hear them rap so every time
like we make something pop out was like
the first like
fun just energetic record every time we
make something we try to go even like
big homie both of y'all were going in
yeah who's going in on big on me for
sure
yeah that's big yeah
um you've kind of like had the biggest
people in and out of the music industry
get behind you uh Lebron yeah you're
gone and on and on but like what do you
I I think that
well I always tell people about you when
I say why you're great is that you be
saying to illness [ __ ] but you say it in
a way that's so relatable and so like
easy that's why I don't understand how
I'm number five
listen man when everybody else is so
confusing do you want me to lie to you
I'm just saying everybody else is so
confusing but you just said here and
said okay I break it down in a way
that's so relatable so what's more
relatable than results take time
is very relatable and number five
and I don't even know what the [ __ ] I
was gonna say
he was going to say I was one just Fred
your guy
no it is Kendrick's big time it's not
even that he's my guy he's I I told him
because where's my guy too shout out to
Fred I love Fred Fred is always showing
me he had a couple of records that we're
gonna make the album that I was really
worried about because if they would have
made the album
I was very worried about like the
direction of the project if these two
records would have made the album yeah
and they didn't make the album Okay and
like I purposely like I had probably 75
of his album already yeah but it like
purposely didn't listen to everything in
order why didn't you like those two
songs they must have been commercial
yeah you don't like commercial music
okay let me ask you this
what's the most successful record on
Frey's new project
too much
I think that that's the record they're
pushing but I think streaming wise uh I
think the one record that's going up is
the uh the uh [ __ ] Anderson pack
record the one I keep hearing is the
money back record so that record is a
single you don't like that record do you
I like it but I don't love it I love it
it's dope I love it I love that record
shout out to Fred for making that record
that's a dope ass record yeah but I'm
starting to gauge what it is you look
for so you you hate commercial [ __ ] no
that's not true you do I like commercial
[ __ ] no you don't I do no you don't you
just said you don't like the Jeffrey
record that doesn't mean I love bro I DJ
the same like I DJ all the ignorant [ __ ]
bro like I just don't particularly enjoy
that record but that's because you're
not a [ __ ] boy also I didn't like I also
didn't like the record on the last album
the [ __ ] [ __ ] did not even follow me
I hated that record I didn't really like
that record that record was that to me
that record was a stretch it didn't feel
natural the key Glock record feels
natural to you I just I'm just not crazy
about it uh I'm with that yeah I'm with
that I love that record though
if you come to the show coming tonight
you'll like it tonight I bet I will yeah
uh but who else has been like the most
random person that's like just tapped in
like whether it's a someone who's just
we posted your DM do or that Mike Tyson
tide yesterday Mike Tyson and Styles P
oh I saw that yeah with the Angie
Martinez was there yeah yeah that was
dope and I recently ran into a con
in Atlanta great hair oh man he's going
crazy yeah I love that he's going crazy
I'm interviewing him tomorrow tell him I
said what's up I will but I ran into a
Con in Atlanta and he was like yeah man
you know I've been seeing your
freestyles I'm gonna check out your
project so literally about four hours
goes by and my phone ringing right it's
Akon wow I was just about to get on
stage in Atlanta I had like 20 minutes
before I got on stage and he was like yo
he's like man this [ __ ] album is
incredible he was like I ain't heard
nothing like this in five years which I
don't understand why Kev got me at five
um he said I haven't heard nothing like
this in five years this is some real
[ __ ] rap records like you talking
some real [ __ ] some relatable [ __ ] right
which I don't understand why Kev has me
at five but he was like this [ __ ] isn't
[ __ ] incredible I'm like damn con I
really appreciate that because I grew up
like literally watching you like
learning how to write hooks listening to
Akon and T-Pain so the fact that he
rocked with it in boola Kev did it I do
what do you mean I love the album you
said it was number five that's great you
like it you don't love it if I bro I
love every other album I in my top 10 I
have so after that I have like Joey okay
uh what other album I love I love I love
the Kodak Black Album so that's cool I
got a great uh kodak's album is hard
kodak's a generational Talent I think he
doesn't get enough credit I'm really
looking forward to hearing what this
little baby album sounds like too
because yeah my turn was like a classic
so you think it was a classic I think my
turn is yeah I think we're gonna look
back and it's gonna be uh regarded as a
classic for sure I can't argue that yeah
I think I don't think it's a classic now
but I think like over time over time I'm
gonna be like damn you know what I'm
saying yeah that's true yeah I just
think like you know yeah shout out to
baby
um yeah who else is dope this year what
albums did you like
future had the best album of the year to
me
I respect the opinion just to me yeah to
me besides results you got him you got
you were number two there [ __ ] I
got me in one [ __ ] I got me you know
let's just dropped a great album
Uncle few
oh the Migos uh was really good the uh
yeah no it's dope it's dope Angie
herbal's album is Rick she herbo's dope
um yeah no the uh
I'm very sad about the Amigos breakup to
be honest but what happened I don't know
they're all related bro so I don't get
it you know what happened tell people
what happened I don't know what happened
I mean I think it was all about money
contracts QC [ __ ] I don't know well I
don't know but I love I love man damn
it's so sad I love how they recreated
the rayquan I think it's good
why I think sometimes certain things run
his course
but they're related yeah but I think my
thing is if they break up and it's like
amicable they're not it's fine officer
is not related to them oh they're he's
not Cleveland takeoff Israel I thought
they aren't already related in some
capacity I think cuevos takeoff's nephew
correct no I think cuevo is
takeoff's Uncle yes okay yeah he's one
of them but offset was the homie are we
sure yes are we sure yes
they're all related they're all related
yeah no they're all related they can't
all be related
no no no no cuevos don't they can't all
be related
Google it Dwight come on Dwight they
can't all be related they're all related
no they're not quavo and takeoff is
related officer it's the homie what was
the homie look it up
I guarantee
wow
I told you we're both of them well I
knew that they were related damn no
that's a great album though yeah no I
listened to it yesterday it was real
good rock Marciano has Adobe album with
Alchemist yeah stove God cooking up some
dope [ __ ] too I just seen him the other
day in New York the uh
Rome Street's album is dope too shout
out to him yeah you got to get him with
like I want to hear you again with the
Alchemist bro I'm ready man I've been
talking to Alchemist me and uh the
legendary Pete Rock been talking that'll
be hard yeah but you gotta get in with
ALC you got a studio Santa Monica I'm
with it I'm with it I actually met him
through you
through you well I'm sure we'll get in
soon what up y'all we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our new
sponsors our family at hardean Las Vegas
you see what it is you see what it is
welcome to the family heart Dean man
we're so excited I've been going to
Harding for so many years for people who
don't know Hardin is that premium
cannabis dispensary the number one
award-winning dispensary in Las Vegas
I'm talking the biggest and best
selection of cannabis product and of
course in Vegas but I'm talking about
worldwide they're them [ __ ] all
right so what you got to do is pull up
when you're in Vegas to hardine go to
Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot them
that follow on Instagram go see them
tell them I sent you when you go to
check out be like yo bootleg Kev sent me
I saw y'all talking about it on the
bootleg cat podcast look when you're in
Vegas they'll also deliver right to your
room whatever you need all right make
sure you follow the crew Harding
underscore loss Vegas go to hardeen Las
Vegas com that's
j-a-r-d-i-n Las vegas.com and don't
forget when you go to Vegas you go to
Jardine tell them I sent you and they're
gonna you only might throw a little
extra little eighth in the bag or
something give a little discount the
bootleg discount you know what I'm
saying get them packwoods too they give
me a Packwood the other day that geez
I'm still recovering from that [ __ ] blew
my whole [ __ ] face off in the best
way Hardy in Las Vegas all right shout
out to them let's get back to the
interview hey let's uh you know what
kind of me and you always have these
talks about kind of like you're you have
a pretty unique path to where you are
right now yes most uh
like you're a new artist but you're not
a new artist I'm a new artist well
you're a new artist to the world but I
feel like your grind is not new for sure
like um kind of give us a little bit of
background on just like
give me let's start up like when you're
running around with DJ amen oh wow so
um and you were managing artist too yeah
so before I actually wanted to be an
artist I was managing artists right so
it was an artist named young Kurt shout
out to Young Kirk
um a lot of people know Kirk music you
remember the [ __ ] on my mama that girl
no yeah so Kurt had like a bunch of
songs and we were running around and I
was just telling this story earlier like
Kurt was like
not the most friendly person you know so
it was kind of tough to like get them to
talk to program directors and promoters
yeah Network and do the [ __ ] you got to
do yeah so I naturally had to go do that
work yeah which kind of made me more of
a people person and understood how to
talk to people and deal with people in
Industry so me and Kirk ran into some
differences and I started doing my own
thing and just me naturally seeing what
it took to kind of like to cut through I
applied that to what it was I was doing
the problem was my music was just
terrible at the time right so people
rocked with me as a person but the music
wasn't all the way there so I would
notice that I would notice when I play
my music and somebody else would play
something I'd be like damn my [ __ ]
wasn't hitting like that right got
around a bunch of different songwriters
a bunch of different producers signed my
first deal at Columbia
immediately realized I wasn't a priority
in the building when I realized I wasn't
a priority in the building about a week
later it was a regime change where
everybody who signed me over there and
brought me in and left and went to a new
label right so I was stuck on this label
being a traditional rapper that got
signed through writing a song for
somebody else and they wanted me to make
music that type of way who'd you write a
song for I can't tell you that okay I
can't tell you that but it's a
well-known rapper
um Columbia
no oh from New York though but not nas
Legend okay
um not nice not nice okay
um so I was writing this song and they
wanted me to continue to do that JC but
it was like no it was like some Melody
right younger new guy right no okay
um so
so I kept going and
I did that because I was basically broke
at the time yeah I used all my money
moving out here right right so I was
running around buying people drinks
buying tables every night thinking this
is where to get me known right wasting a
bunch of [ __ ] money artists don't
ever think buying DJs and buying table
buying DJ's drinks and buying it doesn't
matter it's going to change your career
it only works when your music is
actually it's got to be dope yeah get
the music first and then do that I
actually like it if I'm DJing and
someone and a rapper comes up to me and
gets me a drink I I hate it yeah because
now I feel like you're using me no I
just feel like
I know this guy thinks I'm going to play
a song now and I feel like he's using
you I'm not gonna play the song I'd
almost rather just you keep the drink
exactly yeah you know so I went through
that whole phase and then
um around 2019 I ran into Dallas Martin
yeah and Dallas is like
he's like the a r that's like always
taking the chance like right he signed
Roddy like he's not really just signing
you because of your following or because
you got a hit record he's signing you
because he believes and he's trying to
change the trajectory of things of how
they may be yeah I feel like that's how
people should get signed based off of
the gut based off the music not off the
metrics the problem is is people like
bullet Kev that caused my album number
five and and all these other records get
streamed because of what he just said
but that's neither here nor there so
people like Dallas got to take a chance
on me because people like bullet Kev
caused my album number five okay so
shouts out to Dallas Martin for taking
that chance because without him I just
be number five
so shout out to Dallas
you're a dick
Jesus I was gonna say though like
I always have like a
I love Bay Area Music yeah but I always
feel like the music that gets embraced
out of the bay it almost only gets
embraced if it sounds a certain way
Taylor Regional like we have a guy named
John Coston who we probably both know
he's a slimy bastard shout out to John I
love him yeah but like I'm the slimiest
of the slimiest but like you know when
I'm talking to him about like yourself
or guys like little Russell I feel like
the excitement's not there as opposed to
if I'm talking to him about like they
want us to put guns in the video I don't
know I'm just it's just frustrating
because I'm like yo sometimes I feel
like how is it in my opinion you and the
Russell in my opinion are like the next
like Jay-Z and like Nas like little
Russell's gonna change the music
industry based off of his business model
the music is good like you're just like
I think the new hope you know what I'm
saying and I feel like
up until like everybody outside of the
bay was [ __ ] with you it didn't feel
like the people inside of the bay were
[ __ ] with you you know
Coca-Cola was the first Cola to be a
brand
they didn't take
the heat of Pepsi too much when it first
came around right all right so Pepsi had
to become the drink of the generation so
it related to a new demographic and
what's going on is me and larussa are
relating to a different demographic than
what typically you see in the bay right
so because of that you're going to get
class you're going to get a little push
back because people have been doing it
one way for so long they look at it like
who the [ __ ] are y'all right to come
change what the [ __ ] is going on and
that's cool we're not trying to change
what's going on he's trying to offer
some balance we just want to relate to a
broader audience and me and the Russell
talk about this a lot same thing with
Rex life Raj who's incredible yeah same
thing with a little Kayla you know like
everybody's looking to expand we tired
of being in the city that just get
looked at as like the little cousin of
LA right you know what I mean it's like
we bigger than that we could be bigger
as well but sometimes our music doesn't
translate because well you guys don't
also like make like traditional at least
what we look at as Bay Area records yeah
you know what I'm saying and to me
that's like I think that that is why I
love the bay because I love Bay Area
Music but I also feel like it is also
what makes the ceiling a little bit
harder to break through because it is a
bit Regional fix and you know like being
down here like I remember last year was
a bunch of people that felt like I was
actually from L.A right you know people
that actually see me in the bay working
and putting working for years like oh
yeah L.A [ __ ] but it's like nah I'm
just trying to expand it I'm trying to
do something different than just we all
get hot go to Petaluma go to Fresno go
to Sacramento go to Seattle
what comes after that right why can't we
be on the level of a Kendrick even if
bootleg Kev caused the album number five
and Kendrick number two why can't we be
on the level of a Freddie Gibbs even
though bootleg cave calls it number five
why can't we be on a level we get it we
get it you know so we gotta make bigger
records and we got to stick together
because people like bootleg Kev has it
um
called the project number one but he has
went to the Russell's backyard so we we
appreciate that I was definitely in
Vallejo yes I stayed in the hotel we
live in the crest we loved it shout out
to the Russell too because he's doing
amazing [ __ ] by the way the uh Hampton
Inn right across the street from that
7-Eleven in Vallejo and the cross street
my hotel that for two nights was in
Vallejo he was in the crest world it was
[ __ ] lit no we was at uh what's the
name of that liquor store King's Liquor
yeah it's great I had the Mac Dre soda
yeah you know Vallejo is a very cultural
place no it's great yeah we had good
food there great Asian food that's an
old Vallejo
um were you in the Russell I mean
everybody's been asking you're gonna do
a new out like you're gonna do an album
with them you're talking about it oh EP
or something it's timing it's just
trying to figure it out like he got a
lot going on I got a lot going on we've
definitely been like talking a lot more
um anytime I'm in the bay I always go
over to his spot we always link up but
it's like every time we link up
it's more of like a
it's more of like a conversation than it
is about music because we so inspired
about being Innovative that we always
trying to think of like what's the next
move for the future more so than making
a song right so it's it's definitely
gonna come it's just timing it's a
matter of time yeah who else from the
bay are you [ __ ] with Jr's dope yeah
that's my boy right there I just brought
him out in Vegas young J.R he's dope I
like little Kayla uh Rex life Raj
um who else I've been listening to I
also like that kid I think his name is
DB by the bag but I think he's out of
like Stockton or something like this
Stockton's going up right now yeah he's
dope
um it's a few people that's dope Blaster
there's a few people I rock with us got
some great [ __ ] going on you said on
your intro that somebody had told you
you needed to do a song with kafani
Canard Canard Canard was the program
director at KMEL when I was living in
the Bay Area and I was bringing him
records
um that we're not the typical sounding
Bay record but they were good records he
would tell me that I need a Bay Area
sounding record or a feature from kafani
if I wanted to be played that's
interesting and I thought that was a
very
small-minded way of looking at things
because it was like okay so you're just
gonna dictate what people want to hear
how about you at least get a record a
shot that's why I hate when DJs be like
I don't like the record it's like okay
but what if the people do
because you don't like it like that's
not fair also if you're a DJ you have to
understand that like
there's a if you hear a record you got
to understand like who the record's for
and you also gonna like you like unless
it's a bad record yeah you cannot you
cannot like a song like like you your
song with uh key Glock and Jeffrey are
it's a good record I just personally
don't love it but that doesn't mean it's
a bad record I recognize like what it is
like oh this is hard like you're not the
type of person that won't play it
because you don't like like if somebody
came to you and be like Play Simba and
key Glock I know you'll play it but
there's certain DJs is like I don't like
that recorder I don't have it and they
have it in a system and I just be
thinking that's just like some
yeah I mean listen man I think like DJs
are very important
um but I also think that like
they're not as important as they were
like a decade ago in terms of like radio
radio I'm talking about radio
specifically see that's where my mind be
[ __ ] up because I think I'm with you
on that I think there's a way that they
can be and I think because they'd be so
stuck in traditional ways and not trying
to innovate what the DJs looks like
today
they get stagnant
right so it's a lot of DJs that can kind
of because if you look at it right
streaming tells people what to play so
it kind of [ __ ] up the discovery
process for artists so if you get DJs
linking up with artists now DJs can help
break artists artists can help break DJs
I just don't know
if
a DJ breaking your record in wherever it
is
I don't know how much that actually
correlates
to like people giving a [ __ ] anymore and
I'm I'm on the radio every day in 15
cities yeah I'm telling you I just don't
know if it matters like to me it's the
Final Phase in like making a hit record
a hit record because you're never gonna
like chart really high on Billboard
without radio play yeah but like I feel
like in terms of like garnering people's
interest garnering fans streams all that
[ __ ] I'm not sure
what radio brings to the table unless
you are like in power rotation across
the [ __ ] country which means your
song's already moving anyway yeah I
agree but I think because like if
somebody plays your song at like 8pm on
a Friday night yeah that's dope it's
cool for like IG repost but like the
chance depending on what city it's in
like but that's what I said I think this
has to be an attachment with the DJ and
the artist because DJ's helped the
discovery process right yeah I think I
think I actually think like a DJ playing
your [ __ ] in a big Club over and over
again is even probably like a little bit
more effective than somebody playing
yourself on the radio that's what I'm
saying yeah so it's not just radio it's
having that artist the DJ relationship
to where my DJ right Eerie shout out
Hillary like now okay what was it four
months ago we would only do things in
the bay right right so now we've been on
tour every night when he starts his set
out he's playing never change right so
now when Utah we're in Denver we're in
all these different places so the more
he gets booked it helps me the more I
get booked it helps him right I think
it's the artist the DJ relationship
which can help break up artists today
versus it kind of being like this
divisive thing of
I work for the radio and you need to
make a radio record well also like radio
personalities for the most part are
really entitled [ __ ] yeah who feel
like
they matter more than they do for sure
and I'm a radio guy and it's like but
you're deeper than a radio guy but you
know but I'm saying like it is not in my
best interest to [ __ ] on my own
professional but you can sit here and
have a conversation with anybody most of
them can't right right because these
[ __ ] wasn't the coolest growing
up or they didn't come from certain
environments that we did so it's
different with you because you could do
a podcast you can jump on real 923 you
could jump on bet you could do whatever
it is you need to do to get the job done
everybody can't do that so that little
bit of authority that they have at Radio
they try to hold on to that [ __ ] as long
as they can because that's all they
[ __ ] got yeah yeah I see so many guys
like uh Midwest DJ I was just talking to
my boy but I'm like yeah why is the dude
still carrying himself like his O2 yeah
like what's happening it's 20 22. I
literally was just in the city I'm not
going to say the name of the city but I
was in the city three nights ago and
they was we was listening to the radio
and he was like hottest record in the
city right now and it was Meek Mill I'm
a boss
and I was like bro where the [ __ ] have
you been the last that was 10 years ago
like at least played an intro like Jesus
like it was like what the [ __ ] is going
on yeah so it's it's it's it's it's it's
hard yeah were you were you ever trying
to make those records like do you
definitely yeah definitely definitely I
still attempt it sometimes I mean the
thing is is like you could do it but
it's Gotta Be organic gotta be organic
like dude when two chains did I'm
Different it didn't sound like 2 Chainz
was joking [ __ ] L.A it just sounded
like he made a hit exactly you know what
I'm saying exactly we got it when yo
gotti hopped on uh it was like this [ __ ]
is natural this is Erp 100 yeah yeah it
just got to be done right and I think
sometimes as West Coast artists it's a
little different for us because our
music moves a little faster true and the
sound of today is more so of a trap
sound which is slower yeah the National
Sound yeah so some of the records that
work over in the South doesn't work over
here but some of the records vice versa
over here doesn't work over there so I
think that's why Roddy was so smart
but not only was it that you could
understand them yeah so a lot of times
like us being from the West we don't
comprehend with the southern accent as
well right Roddy made it to where you
could kind of like Get It Right right
away no matter where you was at shout
out to the rich guy too man my boy Roddy
Rich yeah he was one of the later
features that got added right yeah but
because I don't see him had a record
before
you remember I played it for you a long
time ago we couldn't get that one clear
I better say you guys are pretty much
got the same a r same
man no he was cool got you it was cool
before that because he had uh did
something for one of the homies back
before I even had met Dallas so we knew
me him and Kiefer in cash had a
relationship
um before I even had met Dallas so it
just came full circle
yo it's bootleg Kev here to tell you
about our partners at my bookie damn it
football season we're in the thick of it
right now I hit big last week too man I
want to give a shout out to uh to my guy
who gave me the picture all my guys
sports book Killer but listen what you
got to do is go to my bookie right now
get in on this NFL action you know NBA
is coming up too you could bet on
anything you want they got the player
props you could do the a parlay Builder
you could bet on your favorite team to
win the Super Bowl get them odds up
whatever it is the most important thing
get that first time deposit bonus that
means when you sign up for your account
use the promo code bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g and you will get a deposit
match so if you put in 200 they're gonna
give you two hundred dollars on top of
that to gamble with for free if you put
in a thousand dollars they're gonna
match that deposit with a free thousand
dollars for you to gamble with right now
so what the [ __ ] are you waiting for
let's get this money let's watch some
[ __ ] football and let's get paid with
my bookie who uh are you like a fan of
just as a MC like obviously you love
future yeah best album of the year
that's my favorite rapper ever yeah
that's interesting yeah ever ever all
time over hope
they like 181b that's interesting yeah
future all time yeah for me he's the
greatest Club artist of all time no he's
hilarious and he's a lyric he's one of
the best players he's one of the best
songwriters ever but for me it's lyrics
that relate to My Life True it probably
doesn't relate to everyone else so
you're a drug addict no I'm not a drug
addict
I love having fun yeah
um I love looking at life from different
views I love future I love women I love
vacations I wouldn't put them I wouldn't
put him in in the top ten though I just
said he's mine I respect it our personal
life I think remember that Meme that was
going around like two years ago and it
was like field of Mount Rushmore in it
was Drake Kendrick and Cole I think
future is the fourth one
of this generation I agree yeah
yeah yeah or yeah not Travis future it's
future it's for sure future for sure
it's future for sure it's not even close
not close
future yeah cause what Tony Montana was
2010 or 11 2010. was it 2010
all this [ __ ]
it might have been 2011. it's 2010 or
2011. but either way it goes no he's not
a decade run and it's pretty crazy and
he's wild still going still going and
the new album like he had dropped a few
albums recently that I was like but the
new album the new low was just the one
yeah that was great oh [ __ ] for sure man
and he's probably like top
six or seven most influential guy ever
in rap
I wouldn't be mad at five you got my
album at five I mean you could at least
put future and she's top five most
influential because it's like it's it's
probably like who's your top five most
influential in hip-hop I think it's
Tupac and I'm just not in no order okay
Tupac whole
actually not Jay-Z I'm sorry
Jay-Z's not tough wait wait wait hold on
I'm thinking in order
I think like overall in the game like
all time like who made it okay to really
rap rock him and I know that's like some
old head [ __ ] to say because that's
before my journey but he was like the
first dude I'm with you on that because
before Rock him nobody was really doing
this right everywhere people walking
around Tupac Rock him Hove
Kanye and Lil Wayne
I can't argue that because Kanye I
cannot argue Has Changed music hip-hop
like four times I cannot argue that and
then it's like future Chief Keef yeah
Drake Drake even now I can't even say
that because musically he didn't have no
one to get slipped on oh Ace Hood
a great guy great great physique so many
people stole Ace hoods there yeah I I
got people have made careers off of Ace
Hood sounds listen don't say a statement
like that and not tell me who's stolen
his style a lot of people give me one
name you want to do it the the the Migos
flow the Migos flow comes from an Ace
Hood style really
yes I guess I'm not listen to Listen to
early Ace Hood and listen to okay we're
not gonna put Ace Hood in the top ten
though I'm not saying you can put them
wherever you want to put them what I'm
saying is he gets he slept on that's
fair he's a great MC has taken his style
and ran with him okay there's early Meek
Mill songs okay that feel like I'm not
saying Meeks though they came at the
same time so they kind of fed off each
other but that style of Hustle Hard
definitely underrated in my pocket
drink nothing with no profit when I
double up with my profit that whole Flow
came from Ace Hood the same way [ __ ]
rap today all right well acid gets his
flowers today Shout Out Days very
underrated discography too very
underrated yeah very underrated shout
out days most fit rapper
most fit that [ __ ] yoked more
than 50 Cent yeah what did you see 50
hanging upside down at the Super Bowl
look like a TV put some weight on you
though man now Ace Hood is like a
[ __ ] specimen pause like that
[ __ ] is like a goddamn he's like
The Rock
have you seen him lately no bro he's
[ __ ] jacked really like jacked it's
like
it's like he he should he should be like
fighting or playing football or
something he's [ __ ] know that I knew
he was always like a fit no no no he's
like no he fit guy it's like him and
Method Man is it him in the Rock no the
I'm talking about hip-hop like Method
Man's also pretty what about him and Vin
Diesel
I think uh Vin Diesel is probably more
flabbier than Ace Hood for sure okay
yeah okay what about the Rock and Vin
Diesel the rock is a [ __ ] alien yeah
all right did you see the baby
that they was passing around in the
Crowd Oh I thought you meant baby I'm
gonna get a baby's kind of in all right
shape
yeah they crowd surfed the baby
yeah I don't know that was a newborn
baby just getting passed through a crowd
to go to the rough and The Rock's just
like
[Music]
that kid's parents need to be detained
how do you feel about
um artists saying that they're
blackballed nowadays
speaking of the baby
some of them are
but what does that mean
I think Blackboard is when you've pissed
a certain person off that has the
authority to make a call to stop your
emergence
he can stop your momentum for sure but I
think if you have real fans I don't
think but that's the problem most people
don't have real fans they have fans of
songs so when the sound dies out so do
they and they never build an underbelly
that's why I appreciate my dog joining
Lucas for taking me on this tour because
he's got those fans yes and it's
allowing me to convert them in December
fans yeah and they'll learn about me and
that's why you got a guy like Tori who's
always had like that super strong core
following but Tori's a different thing
see but I'm saying Tori can say you know
I've been blackballed from playlists
which has definitely happened but it
doesn't matter because he still had the
best-selling album of the week but he's
an anomaly because that motherfucker's
talented oh he's an alien everybody's
not that talented most people aren't as
talented as Tory Lanez ain't got that
talent to be able to wiggle through that
[ __ ] so some people
it kind of forced to take a back seat
because they can't do some of them
things that he could do so he's he makes
timeless music consistently like he's an
anomaly he's an alien talented level
persifex for sure everybody ain't got
that that's real everybody ain't got
that and if you don't have that you're
trying to cut through and you didn't
piss the wrong people off it's going to
be tough yeah I understand like what
Russ was saying because Russ was like
you can't be blackballed if there's the
internet he's right but he's also that's
not true there's no context sometimes
too and I [ __ ] with Russ right no no
this doesn't say there's no context to
he's right but
that doesn't mean that somebody can't
stand in the way effects of opportunity
that will leave like like elevate your
whole entire [ __ ] like which is why he
is right and saying if you have a core
fan base you'll be fine nobody can
blackball you but you can if someone
doesn't put you on rap caviar on purpose
and I'm not saying that's ever happened
for sure because I want to put that on
Carl or anybody over there but if
someone doesn't put you on a playlist on
purpose because something you did or you
said or they don't like you
and it and that's the only reason they
didn't put you on it that playlist could
be the difference between an extra five
million streams and everybody's every
the way everybody built their career is
different so Russ had the ability to
build his career through SoundCloud and
touring and right building out and
making different type of records that
somebody like the baby wouldn't get off
if he was in that position right you
know what I mean and the baby also came
up with like a pretty solid core
Foundation no for sure what I'm just
saying it's going to be tougher for
somebody like the baby than it would be
for us right right and it's a whole
bunch of different reasons that go into
that but everybody's my whole point is
everybody's journey is different so you
just can't say that someone can't be
blackballed that's what I mean the
internet I think because I think both I
think both sides are correct yeah
because there's context to both sides
yeah it's two sides of it you know what
else is important something you said
earlier when you return with your artist
you're managing yeah you kind of have to
have people like want you to win oh yeah
you like people kind of have like either
they have to like you or you got to be
Kanye West for sure for sure that's what
I'm saying Tori is an anomaly or you got
to be NBA young boy where it's like it
doesn't anomaly and not yeah there's
nothing you can do
NBA young boy just dropped the album
what was it Friday I think he's put out
110 songs this year okay listen to this
right NBA young boy just put an album
out Friday yeah he just announced
another one today it's crazy
it's nothing you could do about it
Dwight is he helping keep the lights on
over there
he's contributing to those lights cardi
ain't dropped in a while [ __ ] shout out
to cardi because she been flaming them
verses oh my God that tomorrow two
versus crazy she killed it and she just
killed the Munch beat I I haven't I saw
she got on I didn't hear it though yeah
she's been killing verses yeah she's I'm
excited to hear some new Cardigans you
know what I say about cardi cardi
delivers records I don't know if she's
writing or not writing I don't give a
[ __ ] she's delivering them records
delivered so hard it doesn't matter she
doesn't she doesn't have to write if she
don't want to yeah and I'm sorry 100 uh
are you have you been helping people on
the with the pen behind the scenes I
haven't been lately but in the past you
know that's kind of how I got my name
though yeah but um lately no I haven't
uh I really haven't been in the studio
in like the last few months in a couple
months right I got in the other day
because I'm working on some stuff with
the Warriors and I had a few features to
do but uh and it was fun because I
haven't been in there in a minute and I
was kind of like in results take time
mode to where I was trying to make songs
working on draymond's disc to Jordan
pool no no that's not coming okay good
but uh it was fun to be in the studio
though so I'm excited to get back in and
like being on the road it's made me
understand
um different tempos yeah and different
Sonics and like why certain records hit
a certain way they do so I'm starting to
look for a different type of production
going into this next project what is uh
something you've learned from just being
around Joyner for a month
man a lot bro
um I would say he's got the best videos
in the game
I've got one of the best Minds in the
game yeah his team is great right
um they're very focused they pay
attention to detail very close
um they're very concerned about how the
fans receive the show right even the
music
um they're always thinking of ways to be
Innovative and own brand
oh but one thing I remember after I
think it was like the third night
I kept like because I would kill I'd be
killing every show yeah and then I'll
walk out and then it was one night where
they was they was like chanting like Sam
but after I walked off the stage and he
was like yo he's like you got to start
going out there taking pictures
but I'm thinking like I'm thinking like
[ __ ] I Gotta Get Out The Way suit you
know what I mean he's like nah go out
there take it you don't want to be the
guy who while the headliner is closing
there's like a line of people trying to
take a picture exactly that's something
take away from his shine he was like nah
you got to take the pictures so the next
day I start taking the pictures and I
start watching my following go up he
came to me the next day he was like you
gotta tell him to tag you in the
pictures yeah you know what I mean
that's how you you get them die hard
yeah like I went up like I think like
120 000 followers just in the last month
just getting on the road album coming
out yeah yeah yeah that shit's crazy
yeah it's been dope bro it's been a
great experience and you've been killing
it on the sink [ __ ] it's crazy because
you got uh the in the game record that
is my son's favorite song really yes my
eight-year-old yeah he's like loves that
[ __ ] song that's dope we actually
just uh got word that the NBA is gonna
be doing something with that this season
as well nice and that's a long lead
right here on the boots that's not even
a song on your uh on your album
I feel like those records do well
um because they're like all purpose
records right and me sometimes as an
artist I'd be so concerned about
building out who the Simba fan is I
naturally try to run away from them
records on projects they're like build
the fan base out but I'm slowly starting
to see how they perform on the road so
I'm like I need to mix this in a little
more so you uh the first project came
out in December 2020 yeah we just got
the the newest yeah the gangster grills
yeah
number number five album of the Year
correct the fifth best album of the year
yeah
um yeah what an accomplishment
it is yeah it's a great accomplishment I
wrote all those verses to be number five
guys
I mean that's better than ninth
still five anyway
um
hey what up y'all it's bootleg Kev here
to stop the interview sorry uh but we
gotta pay the [ __ ] bills and you know
not only do we have to pay the bills but
we also gotta take care of them [ __ ]
out there that's right make sure you go
to bluetooth.com right now you know the
bootleg kept podcast we are presented by
bluetooth proudly I happen to every once
in a while dabbling a little chooski you
know what I'm saying and let me tell you
something my dick thanks me for it every
single time uh so listen if you go to
Bluetooth use the promo code bootleg
you're gonna get your first month supply
for free now we're talking the same
active ingredient as Viagra as Cialis
without the awkward doctor's appointment
visit you just go online they get you
taken care of it gets delivered right to
your [ __ ] door and discreet packaging
it's a beautiful thing and how about
this
brand new product alert on Bluetooth all
right and I'm gonna [ __ ] this up for
sure so I'm gonna try to read it uh now
Bluetooth has a mint flavored chewable
with
bardenophil which is the same active
ingredient in Levitra and staxin
so shout out to Levitra
same active ingredient in the mint
flavor chewables so what are we doing go
get you a little mint boy go get you a
little blue chew whatever the [ __ ] you
need just know
whatever young lady or man or Etc that
you're dealing with they're gonna
[ __ ] thank you for it because your
dick's going to be harder than it's ever
been in your whole [ __ ] life man it's
gonna be great and like if you're a
single guy
take a blue chew
jack off
be a better jerk I'll tell you that all
right bluetooth.com go right now
and uh you know I know we have a lot of
male listeners who like underground rap
so chances are you're not getting a lot
of [ __ ] but I promise you one thing you
take that blue too you're gonna beat
your dick like it stole some all night
long bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg right now and they will give you
the first month for free so go do that
[ __ ] how long are we gonna wait till you
make a new body of work it's not gonna
be long right
um
I'm literally I was just talking to my
team the other day like we finished tour
tomorrow
I'm gonna chill with my son for a little
bit and I'm about to get to Atlanta get
to Miami get to New York and go to Santa
Monica and get in with the Alchemist
yeah yes get get in with Dre get in with
Dre yeah yeah get in with a bunch of
people and uh I'm trying to I'm trying
to put something out like
before summer so before so that's for
sure yeah but I'm gonna be dropping
music singles yeah it might drop a four
pack you know a couple two packs but the
next project for sure trying to get it
out before summer for you
um
what do you feel like is the biggest
uphill battle being and don't say having
your album be number five
um
just being an artist in today's uh
landscape that is more on the lyrical
side that is more like I I always
compare you to Jay-Z because I feel like
you remind me so much of him in terms of
talent but also in terms of persona yeah
um like you guys are not trying really
hard you're just cool [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying you're likeable but
what is the biggest challenge just being
Simba in in today's hip-hop game like
like
talk about that sometimes
living in the future too much
um
I've recently seen Kanye say something
or he was like I might not be right I'm
just not right right now
you know what I mean except to say he's
wrong about a couple I feel like right
now but yeah like what I don't know the
White lives matter there was a stretch
okay I got a take on that okay we'll get
to that finish your finish your point
and then we'll go there okay sometimes I
feel like I live in the future so much
to where I'm thinking so far beyond
what's going on right now I'm not
seeing what I can do to better my
situation at the moment I'm always kind
of thinking first I'll drop a project
and instead of like
coming up with all these different
content ideas to continue to push the
project right I'm already on okay this
works for tour they like these drums
they like these Sonics this needs to be
the next connection but I'm already
moved on like Christmas didn't already
passed in my head I didn't already
brought my son gifts I know I'm getting
everybody so I'm in January you know and
sometimes it's it hinders you because
you missing what's going on right in
front of you so I feel like that's
that's one thing and also like
being from the bay
um
and trying to be somebody that's doing
something a little different than what
typically goes on in the bay is an
uphill battle because sometimes you go
through these like
who the [ __ ] does he think he is
conversations right you know issues to
where it's just like I don't think I'm
better than nobody I'm just trying to
expand what the [ __ ] it is we doing all
the way around the board right and
sometimes they could get taken the wrong
way but I would say those are the two
things I mean if you think of like the
biggest rapper commercially besides MC
Hammer yeah and E40 obviously longevity
yeah but it's G-Eazy in terms of just
success now maybe not currently it's not
like on fire but I mean just Peak Peak
Fame you know what I'm saying from the
Bay from the bay Peak Fame and I'm not
telling you since MC Hammer Too Short
yeah what easy over too short what do
you mean he he headlined a a [ __ ] 18
000 seat [ __ ] tour okay if you're
using your white privilege right now no
no we're just talking about what are you
talking about you'd put G-Eazy over too
short yeah Peak you're [ __ ] crazy
Peak Fame hit [ __ ] crazy what you're
[ __ ] crazy no no I'm not talking
about you know how many people know too
short
I'm not talking about
Fame I'm not talking about longevity I
mean like who had the highest peak
G-Eazy never had to peaked it too short
at that's not true
Too Short made the world say [ __ ] oh my
God what are you talking about
listen
what are you talking about
nah what are we talking about I'm
talking about Peak Peak we're talking
about Jeezy who's never bigger than Too
Short that's not true no at a moment yes
no
I said okay if we're taking that's why I
said E40 with the longevity but if we're
talking about
who had the craziest like two like we're
talking about this motherfucker's got a
diamond record that's fine Diamond pit
bull got Diamond records Oak and maybe
Vanilli got diamond right now listen
Pitbull is arguably the biggest rapper
from Miami ever
now I'm not saying I love Pitbull's
music Pitbull is probably the biggest
pop star from Miami but he got the
biggest rapper he's also a rapper he's a
pop star so what's a Drake a pop star so
it's G-Eazy so you can't compare [ __ ]
G-Eazy to cultural ass too short I'm not
saying two shorts are not the culture
and I'm not saying too short isn't
culturally more relevant and important
I'm not saying too short is bigger bro
I'm not saying listen how about we he's
bigger for the culture how about we
compare this sales
yeah let's see
I just okay just too short have a
diamond single it doesn't matter it's
blow the whistle Diamond it might be I
don't know let's look that up let's blow
the whistle Diamond Dwight
this is a crazy conversation Kev
you're you're crazy right now I am how
about this how about this watch this
name of Jeezy record me myself and I no
limit
what do you want me to do name a two
short record
blow the whistle getting it oh you gonna
do that what do you want you're gonna do
that okay cocktails I see what we're
doing cuss words what do you want me to
do I see what you're doing bro as a kid
and this is no offense to G because I
[ __ ] with you I Love Too Short what are
you talking about I love it it's not
bigger than too short I'm not saying
overall I mean like at the peak no who
was who was doing arenas from the bay
imagine [ __ ] too short with social
media in the 90s bro we're not we can't
we can't do that okay but we can imagine
G-Eazy with social media right so we
can't take that away okay okay so can I
just ask you one question okay
whose headline Arenas in the United
States outside of the Bay
since MC Hammer but I'm asking
from the bay all right I'm a rapper
it's only one answer
it's a G-Eazy from the bay this headline
but Jeezy's a pop star
and he's a rapper no he's a pop star
okay that's fair
it's rap music bro he's a pop star okay
but but can you answer the question to
the answer I just I I just answered I
don't know a rapper but we was just so
who is it so answer the question who's
the rapper pop star G okay
she's the same guy who brought 40 on the
road I am Sue on the road kailani on the
road pilo on the road bro the bay up
like it's people who wouldn't have a
sustainable career so since MC Hammer we
can agree that the only rapper to
headline Arenas across the country since
M.C Hammer cause you got people like I'm
not gonna send some Hammer I didn't do
my research I gotta do my research who
is the who else I don't know right off
the bat but G's a pop star and he's a
rapper rapper he's a pop star he's a
rapper though he's a pop star bro name
one rapper that could [ __ ] make me
myself and I
uh [ __ ] Drake could make that song
man Drake's a pop star okay Drake's also
around Drake's a legend there's a
phenomenal rapper he's incredible he's
top tier top tier for sure but she's a
pop star logic could have made me myself
no he [ __ ] wouldn't Roger could have
what he told me he made the suicide
record that [ __ ] was hard but it wasn't
me myself and I so so you're saying he
could make that because he had no if
he's cool enough is g to sell it okay so
because they're both because he made a
song that went who's a better rapper G
or logic I think logic is better okay
yeah lyrics he's a pop star bro but he's
a rapper he raps on pop records no no
limit is a rap song random is a rap song
what are we talking about was cardi B
song man West Coast is a rap song uh
so I so I won just so we know no you
didn't win you didn't win I'm gonna do
my research because what I didn't say
was I did not say Too Short wasn't
bigger in the culture and more important
I didn't say that
I'm saying metrically
at their Peak
it's G-Eazy you know what and he made
records that weren't and but he also
made some Bay Area [ __ ] he made like
calm down I and you might you're right
he is white so he he had a lot of Too
Short can't do some of that [ __ ] G-Eazy
dude I don't disagree he's a pop star
bro I don't listen we we I was trying to
bring the conversation around to saying
that
G was huge because he made
non-traditional
Bay music like no limit is not it's 88
bpms yes think about think about okay
think if
a black person made the same music Jeezy
made you're right I'm gonna work I'm not
saying you're you're right I agree fully
so he's a pop star yo he's a white
rapper because rappers don't have the
privilege to do what pop stars do Eminem
is a white rapper who if somebody and
imagine if somebody tried to make just a
rap like Eminem or Jesus no but if
someone doesn't get the [ __ ] crazy I
agree
but we can't just take them out of we
can't ignore the numbers this is all I'm
saying I'm not ignoring you you're right
saying they're enhanced because of a
certain demographic you're right
that's all I'm saying can it be true
that both of us are right
no because I'm top five on your albums
of the year so somebody gotta win so
we're both right
we're both right well we'll agree to
disagree White lives matter tell me your
take on Kanye's t-shirt okay
a white man owns the slogan black lives
matter
what if Kanye owns the slogan why lives
matter can I break some news right now
okay my best friend in the entire world
is a black man Ramses
owns White lives matter
is he linked with Kanye no no oh well I
don't know
Connie don't own it but a black man does
a black man owns White lives matter
right now so Kanye's promoting black
businesses yeah I mean
I don't think Kanye knew that because he
just bought the phone number
what if he did know you don't think it's
a little like a like uh
I'm not saying I agree right I'm just
saying instead of
us all bashed let's see what's the
madness behind it like does he own this
slogan I know Candace Owens has a
documentary coming out about all the
money black lives matter stole from
people is this merch for that
so my thing is is a couple of things can
be right one black lives matter the
organization yes clearly [ __ ] some
[ __ ] yes right yes I donated I also
I'm glad I talked to Killer Mike when
all that was happening because he told
me who to give money to and I gave it to
like not like I gave it to a lot of our
money with the Joe Budden
whoever it went yeah so that's true
right yes the [ __ ] Foundation is
obviously corrupt yes
what also is true is the term black
lives matter is factual and the reason
why it became a thing was because it is
pretty evident that in the United States
black lives have never been valued in
the same way White lives have been
valued right so I think in in the spawn
of like black lives matter becoming this
movement that a lot of old white people
associated with riots and violence and
[ __ ] for sure
White lives matter became the opposite
or all lives matter became like the
super like crazy
redneck Trump Mega hat wearing ass thing
to say so it so the term White lives
matter is also true White lives matter
sure they do yes all lives matter all
lives of course all lives but it's not
about all lives or what I just think
that that when you say White lives
matter it like it it it's not just the
term like when Kanye said on Tucker
Carlson I said it because it's true like
he's not wrong but at the same time like
the symbolism of wearing that I think
that's where it gets
combative because it's like
exactly what you're saying it comes
across as you're going against just to
do it well yeah just stir it always yeah
but I don't think at the level Kanye's
at
and you know I could be wrong that he
would just do that to do that yeah I
think there's definitely some type of
method behind it and there's something
coming behind I don't know what it is
but what I'm going to say is until I
fully know I'm not just going to develop
an opinion and just be like oh [ __ ]
Kanye because he wore a white lives
matter I want to see what's the method
behind it now if it's solely him just
being a dick you know what I mean and
want to be competitive then I'm not for
that right but if it is something behind
it to where he's trying to change a
narrative let's see how I pass and I
understood like his reasoning for
wearing the Trump hat because I I think
his thing I didn't get that so I
understood it because he essentially was
saying
you don't have to like the Democratic
party is taking advantage of the black
vote forever for sure the whole reason
why Joe Biden is the president is
because I think it was the South
Carolina has anybody seen Kamala Harris
she's from your city right has anybody
seen her
I don't know man have you ever seen her
she's she shout she she got I haven't
seen her since she was yes Joe we've did
it we did it Joe I haven't seen her I'd
like to see you come on let's come
outside but I think him wearing the Maga
hat was a point to be made that hey
we're not automatic like think freely
think for yourself just because you're
black but that's Kanye yeah that's Kanye
I think sometimes
he's so much of a Ford dinker right it
gets the message gets lost because of
the way it's communicated at times
um I don't think he means any harm I
think he's a disrupter right I think
he's a creative genius
um I just think sometimes he
communicates
his message in a confusing way to
certain people but I don't think we
should bash him for it I think we should
hear him out see how it plays out see
what happens
and if we don't agree we don't agree you
know if you do agree cool if not move on
we gotta stop the interview tell you
about our partners at Odd Socks well
first of all let's check out the brand
new collab
look at these the bootleg capsock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
going to figure out a way to give them
away though uh but look Odd Socks the
most comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're a family man I've been walking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too it's an odd sock right
there that's awesome basic you know what
I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd Socks you
should too they got the crazy licenses
we're talking about Nickelodeon shout
out to Patrick [ __ ] Cheez-Its
Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know what I mean yeah these are the Odd
Socks Basics all right so if you go to
the website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
altogether bootleg Kev and you will save
20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course represented by Odd
Socks and we are proud to say so all
right let's get back to the interview
has uh have you ever like heard of Kanye
[ __ ] with your [ __ ] at all or I
worked with Kanye you've worked with him
yeah I worked on donda for four days in
the Mercedes-Benz Stadium wow what was
the best experiences of My Life
um that's why I said I can't just bash
them because you've been around him you
know him it's it's something to it yeah
like he's always thinking forward that's
what he was living there right yeah yeah
he was there before well he was there
for like a month but I was there for
four days and uh I'd watch them write a
song go in another room do a Melody go
in another room and design a building go
in the cafeteria and have a meeting with
Balenciaga about what the fashion show
needs to look like in 2025 yeah go to
rehearsals go to choreography go back in
the room and tell them joints to make a
beat take a certain part of that beat
and send it to 88 keys like he's he's
just a creative guy you know so it's
like I can't being around somebody like
that it's hard to just say they're
coming from a place of malice that's
fair you know you kind of gotta see it
all the way through because you might
not have the full information yeah so I
gotta wait and see I don't I don't know
I can't just make an opinion being
around Kanye and Dr Dre is creative
processes I've heard on each side are
insane like what was the biggest like
difference I heard Dre's a perfectionist
like a crazy perfectionist Dre is
somebody I would say that
knows where he wants to go and take time
to get there
Kanye is somebody
that takes time to get to where he
doesn't want to go don't know where you
want to go yet like the journey is the
journey free right right so he might
like the destination isn't always known
yeah like he might hear a Beat and like
for instance
I did a certain melody in a Cadence
right right and I did a rap to it he
didn't like the words but he liked the
Cadence right and then he heard a
specific beat and he only liked about
four bars of the beat and then he took
that four bars sent it to another
producer and then changed it so you ever
notice when his songs they had played
for like eight bars and introduced him
like
the change
that's like four or five different
producers all on one ID so he might take
one part of this beat one part of this
beat one part of this beat and figure
out way how to mess him wow and then do
the song on top of that and still bring
in a Mike Dean or Travis Scott or
somebody like that to take it to the
next level so with him it's just
constant creativity but Dre is like
I know where I'm going like I know how
this need to sound I know how this need
to feel I know what I want to say I know
what I want to do he takes his time to
get there but Kanye is just freelance
till we figure it out from what I've
seen wow that's dope yeah that's I mean
because both of those guys are we always
hear about the processes being so
incredible some of the greatest to ever
do it 100 yeah what is your top five rap
albums of all time Simba
top five rap albums and no order in no
order in no order
50 Cent Get Rich or Die Trying oh yeah
Kanye West The College Dropout okay
Jay-Z the blueprint
okay over Reasonable Doubt huh yeah I'm
a blueprint guy that's fair that's fair
um
thug motivation 101
great album I think thug motivation 101
is better than nomadic
I respect your opinion I don't agree but
I respect it why don't you agree I just
like Illmatic illmatics why because
everybody says it's a classic I mean Naz
is my favorite MC of all time when's the
last time he lives in Deal mad yesterday
I was listening to New York State of
Mind just a [ __ ] hip Hopper that's
all what do you want from me man it's a
hip Hopper man it's ten songs it's a hip
hop no I love I love listen tm101 is
[ __ ] Exquisite I listen to that album
more than no matter I think Stillmatic
is better than your magic see the thing
is is there's a song on Stillmatic
called Braveheart Party featuring Mary J
Blige that is one of the worst Nas songs
ever and it's not one of the words oh
that song's [ __ ] terrible and just
the fact that that is on Stillmatic
takes it out of the conversation in fact
it's such a terrible song that when they
repress Stillmatic like two years later
they took it off have you ever heard of
someone doing that
imagine a song being so shitty that
there's certain versions you buy and
it's just not there anymore
it's almost like uh the Trey Song Song
on Teflon Don yeah
[ __ ] that song's garbage yeah it's like
the only it's like the the only song on
Teflon Don that's like
I got you yeah I would say
I see a blue you got one more College
Dropout thug motivation get Richard I
try get rich or die trying and
future monster
I mean he is your favorite rapper right
so it'd only be right if
you had him included in your top five
yeah not quite an album though it was on
DatPiff for a very long time that's the
album yeah that's just during the time
we call everything mixtapes because it
was freed up bro that's fair yeah I
respect it I gotta get Richard I trying
to my top five I got uh I got the
Reasonable Doubt though over blueprint
and I have I have late registration over
uh before of a blueprint guy because I'm
somebody that likes simplistic lyricism
right so I feel like Reasonable Doubt
was so lyrical like it's a hard listen
for me right but blueprint is like very
digestible also I got doggy style in
there doggy style is definitely yeah
definitely in the top it's up there yeah
for sure and then My Beautiful Dark
Twisted Fantasy that's one of the
greatest Hip-Hops albums I actually
think it's the greatest ever it's not my
favorite Kanye album but I think it's
probably the it might be the most
perfect album the rappers ever made it
might be I think that is like one of the
greatest but like you said it's not my
personal favorite my original Kanye
favorite is College Dropout or
um I look really registration what was
the next one graduation graduation yeah
College Dropout and graduation is my
favorite yeah that's fair uh all right
so the album is out yeah results take
time number five album in the world
compared to boola cave top five album of
the Year man yeah
thanks I'm just you know a Jason Kidd
out here number five I mean there's
plenty of years LeBron was fifth in MVP
voting it's not fair how you be the best
player in the world and you're just
number five
sounds like what I'm going through here
at the bootleg Camp Show Ladies and
Gentlemen you can be the best in the
world and be number five so the number
five album of the year is out you could
go support it yeah and maybe it's in
your top one yeah yeah it could be it
could be it's your it's your favorite
album I think it's one yeah I don't I
don't think it's a project out with that
much balance and then you got Futures
album Number Two yeah yeah and Fred
and Kendrick and jid
Pusha T's almost crazy and push your
teeth yeah I just said what was it like
getting pushed on on that record because
that record it was dope man because you
know me and push knew each other for a
minute yeah so it was it was it was dope
because it took us a minute to find the
right record to do but once we kind of
like once I made that I'm glad you put
the original out first though because I
love I love the verse that got left off
The Pusher one yeah yeah first verse the
first verse the best verse because it's
so relatable to Cali yeah yeah like
that's but that's originally when I was
writing the song I was writing it from a
perspective of I was originally about to
make it this
comparison between LA and The Bay right
that's what it felt like yeah yeah I
took a turn and then like all the things
we do to get money to never end up broke
that's tight yeah there it is man look
uh the tour is about to end by the time
this comes out the tour will be over
definitely man thank you to my brother
Joyner Lucas
um you know that's that's become my real
homie while we've been on this road I
appreciate him like a [ __ ] man
he's uh taught me a lot
gave me a big opportunity helped me gain
a lot of new fans tour has been great
yeah I'm excited to get back in the
studio and just bro can we get some
merch
yeah about that what's up with the merch
bro I'm like I'm over here trying to
like yo can I buy a shirt somewhere like
there's no [ __ ] merch what are you
doing you're on tour you should be
selling T-shirts every [ __ ] tour stop
emergency got [ __ ] up
the merch got [ __ ] up was that because
of Atlantic no there's nothing to do
with Atlantic it was the company that we
decided to run with ended up [ __ ] the
merch up and it was a long back order
and this whole thing so he went with a
new company and got new designs and
we'll be having you guys missed out on a
lot of money on the road yeah I'm not
really worried about the money though
yeah the money well you know but you
also it's kind of cool to know that
there's like somebody in St Louis or
wherever the [ __ ] no for sure but I
don't never want to give people some
[ __ ] just to make money off of them I
want people to have a quality t-shirt
quality sweatsuit or whatever I'm
assuming the merch was just was it was
it like a oh you said it was a supply
chain thing yeah but it just wasn't
right right it didn't it didn't come out
right didn't look good
um the quality didn't really look look
as great as we were told it well look
um and me I wouldn't want to sell people
something that I wouldn't wear you know
I mean if I'm not going to wear it why
would I sell it to you and I just felt
like it wasn't something I would wear so
that's beautiful man that quality
control May separate you from a lot of
people yeah so we got we got some merch
on the way though it'll be here just put
the album cover no no no we got some we
got some [ __ ] you could wear to the club
all right some fly [ __ ] there it is
Simba appreciate you brother shout out
to the bootleg podcast I love this guy
right here top five album of the year
come on let's get it